[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui est vital et pourtant
ignoré par la plupart d'entre nous
vital et
ignoré
je dirais l'air qu'on respire c'est
vital et pourtant on en a pas du tout
conscience
ça c'est la nourriture du corps et
l'équivalent pour l'esprit ce serait
quoi alors l'équivalent pour l'esprit
je dirais les connaissances oui plus
exactement les connaissances tacites on
ne peut pas les nommer et pourtant elle
représente la majeure partie de nos
connaissances
nous les développons sans cesse quand
nous accomplissons de nouvelles tâches
quand nous nous on des relations ou
encore par curiosité comme vous le
faites aujourd'hui
pollani a été le premier à démontrer
leur importance dans la science
l'implication personnelle du chercheur
pour son sujet de recherche compte tout
autant que les seuls données objectives
Einstein a développé l'intuition de la
relativité très jeune et pourtant il a
mis des années à le démontrer
scientifiquement la prise en compte des
connaissances tacite peut mener à de
grandes avancées de grandes avancées et
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on vous propose
un moyen d'apprendre plus vite et tout
au long de votre vie et ce moyen c'est
le partage de connaissances tacite allez
je vous donne un exemple j'arrive à un
lundi au bureau avec une idée géniale
Marie Solvay que j'ai une idée oui j'ai
fait une découverte personne n'en parle
et pourtant ça peut trop nous aider oui
oui quand marisolveig dit oui trois fois
je commence à la connaître ça veut dire
accélère ou ça veut dire ok mais comment
je mets ça en place alors cet exemple
peut paraître anodin et pourtant il nous
permet de faciliter notre communication
mais les connaissances tacitent les plus
précieuses sont celles nous sommes le
plus engagés personnellement pour
marisolvegue c'est quand elle ose
l'impossible pour les soldes c'est quand
elle est sur scène par exemple
alors imaginez maintenant un moyen
d'identifier les connaissances
personnelles de chacun d'entre vous les
plus précieuses et de les transmettre au
bon moment nous pourrions ainsi ouvrir
la voie à de nouvelles découvertes de
nouvelles avancées en fait tu as pris
conscience des limites du système
d'apprentissage classique qui est
complètement vertical alors que là le
partage de connaissances tacite c'est
horizontal ça a été quoi le déclic pour
cette découverte c'est quand j'ai
découvert la paillasse un lieu avec une
communauté de chercheurs alors c'est un
entrepôt apparemment vide et pourtant
des groupes de chercheurs explorent leur
sujet avec passion par exemple il y
avait Maïté au sous-sol en train de
construire un cocon de flottaison à la
main pour accéder à la relaxation
profonde c'est un peu le contraire d'une
salle de classe j'ai découvert
l'importance de la liberté d'explorer
pour apprendre et dans cette communauté
de partage c'était quoi ton rôle j'ai eu
envie d'organiser une conférence où
chacun révélerait sa connaissance
engagée et cette conférence a donné lieu
à de nombreux thèmes l'écologie le
climat la science participative deuxième
prise de conscience l'important de la
diversité et de la variété des sources
d'apprentissage pour apprendre et
stimuler notre curiosité intellectuelle
alors chacun a partagé mais alors du
coup comment tu as fait pour que chacun
identifie ses connaissances tacites
alors que justement c'est difficile à
formuler oui nous n'avions pas les
moyens de faire appel à un coach
professionnel mais nous avions les
autres alors nous avons fait cet
exercice ensemble chacun partage une
expérience vécue et reçoit le feedback
d'un père à la fin très rapidement
chacun repart avec 10 feedbacks au lieu
d'un c'est là que j'ai fait une seconde
prise de conscience
l'importance des pères pour accélérer et
révéler les apprentissages et oui
partage feedback cette réciprocité ça me
fait penser à cette hauteur Tina
Rosenberg qui explique que l'influence
des pères peut changer le monde
en fait tu as pris conscience de ça ça
t'a donné envie de faire quoi après de
faire reconnaître cette pédagogie dans
le système éducatif alors je suis allée
toquer à la porte de mon directeur
d'école avec une idée un cours entre
père on vient comme on est et on repart
avec la capacité à apprendre des uns des
autres tout au long de la vie par
exemple toi marisolved tu as fait un
cours sur apprendre à oser un autre sur
le langage des signes et le plus
important c'est que ce cours a duré
trois ans auto-organisé par les
étudiants grâce à une méthodologie que
nous leur avons remis
en fait ce n'est pas complètement
nouveau la classe mutuelle existait déjà
en 1800 et les jeunes arrivaient à lire
et à écrire en seulement trois ans au
lieu de 5 ans avec la pédagogie
traditionnelle alors un cours sans
professeur
un cours sans professeur est-ce que vous
imaginez
et ben oui ça fonctionne grâce à
l'apprentissage entre père apprentissage
entre père qui est basé sur trois
piliers premier pilier c'est
l'expérience on partage des moments de
vie c'est pas du tout théorique c'est
comme si on prenait sa vie comme un
terrain d'apprentissage et ce qui est
étonnant d'ailleurs c'est que deux
auteurs avaient déjà mis le doigt sur le
fait qu'on apprend plus vite grâce à
l'expérience c'est David Kolb et run Fry
alors leur nom ne vous dit probablement
rien cold et Frye mais vraiment je vous
conseille de lire leurs ouvrages ça
c'est pour l'expérience premier pilier
deuxième pilier les forces je réalise
que je savais faire alors que je n'en
avais pas conscience et accentuer ses
forces ça permet d'apprendre beaucoup
plus rapidement d'ailleurs les
entreprises qui déploient les formations
par les forces ont de très bons
résultats elles augmentent de 20% leur
bénéfices elles réduisent de moitié leur
turn-over et ça c'est parce qu'elles
valorise les forces de leur
collaborateur
troisième pilier de l'apprentissage
entre père c'est la pédagogie active je
co-construis le contenu un peu comme
dans une classe renversée ou celui qui
d'habitude reçoit le savoir cette fois
va le transmettre
donc on a nos trois piliers de
l'apprentissage entre père
expérience force pédagogie active
concrètement comment ça fonctionne
l'apprentissage entre père
alors on rassemble des pères des
personnes qui partagent des points
communs et des différences par exemple
10 mètres et maîtresse d'école ils
viennent de villes différentes ils
enseignent des matières différentes mais
ils ont tous un point commun ils veulent
apprendre ils veulent améliorer leur
pratique alors il ne suffit pas de les
rassembler en cercle c'est à eux de
choisir leur père de se répartir les
rôles et chacun à leur tour il raconte
leur expérience
si vous participez à un atelier vous
serez accueilli par un ruissellement de
conversation animée ininterrompu
bienveillant comme on en entend rarement
et alors ça fonctionne l'apprentissage
entre père la dernière fois il y a un
directeur régional attends je te fais
directeur régional je suis embêté j'ai
un groupe de managers j'aimerais qu'il
monte en compétences sur leur posture et
il s'est très difficile il n'accepte
rien qui vient du haut donc les
formations ça fonctionne pas je me dis
que si ça vient des pères Viken culture
très forte du Sud ça pourrait
fonctionner et j'ai entendu parler de
l'apprentissage entre père si ça vient
des pères ce sera mieux accepté et oui
ils ont mis en place un programme mené
par les pairs et les résultats sont là
les collaborateurs ont pris conscience
de l'importance de la gestion des
ressources humaines certains sont même
devenus RH ça a été comme un tremplin
et puis la communauté est maintenant
autoportée ça veut dire que c'est les
collaborateurs eux-mêmes qui organisent
des sessions tous les mois pour
apprendre il se forme de même entre eux
alors l'apprentissage entre père leur a
donné envie d'apprendre
et ça peut aussi leur donner envie de
transmettre
est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé qu'on
vous demande de transmettre quelque
chose que vous avez
mais alors
vous allez pas du tout par où commencer
j'ai vraiment rien original à partager
en plus j'ai pas forcément envie de
faire une conférence comme ça devant
tout le monde et puis qu'est-ce que je
vais y gagner enfin je veux dire je suis
récompensé sur mes performances
individuelles toutes ces peurs on les
comprend
imaginez maintenant des cercles on
mélange les groupes et chacun leur tour
il raconte leur expérience le groupe
pose des questions reformule interroge
prends des notes un peu comme le ferait
un journaliste
et alors au bout de deux heures on a 10
pages de bonnes pratiques 100%
participation et 75% des participants
qui ont envie d'appliquer ce qu'ils ont
découvert
et cerise sur le gâteau ils ont appris à
apprendre
alors vous vous demandez sûrement
comment vous aussi vous pouvez apprendre
en continu et en accélérer
comme on est entre père je pense qu'on
peut bien vous partager deux trois trucs
soyons des chercheurs des chercheurs de
connaissances personnelles en apprenant
des autres et en partageant aux autres
alors en apprenant des autres tout
d'abord on est en démarche appréciative
on a trop l'habitude de voir ce qui
manque et si on cherchait ce qu'il y a
de mieux ce qui fonctionne déjà et qui a
déjà fonctionné avec une attitude humble
en prenant conscience qu'il y a beaucoup
de savoir cachés dans les expériences de
chacun bien au-delà des diplômes et des
titres
avec l'écoute une écoute active qui
reformule qui valide et qui valorise le
savoir des autres
recevoir est important donner les temps
encore plus alors comment partager nos
savoirs
alentov un chercheur montre que nous
accomplissons jusqu'à six projets
d'apprentissage par an sans même nous en
rendre compte
identifions les défis que nous avons
surmontés les efforts importants
d'apprentissage ou encore les moments
les plus engagés ou les plus inspirés
que nous avons vécu
partagez nos vécus est encore plus
puissant que donner des conseils
tous ces apprentissages ont été testés
validé sur le terrain par nous par nos
pères alors gagnant du temps
réutilisons-les et transposons les à
d'autres contextes pour ouvrir la voie à
de nouvelles découvertes alors
aujourd'hui on espère que vous avez pris
conscience que vous avez tous des
talents cachés qui n'attendent que
d'être révélée
on espère que vous avez découvert un peu
l'apprentissage entre père cette
expérience participative qui donne envie
d'apprendre des autres et d'apprendre
aux autres et puis on espère que vous
repartez avec des questions que vous
pouvez poser une posture que vous pouvez
prendre pour vous aussi apprendre tout
au long de votre vie et en accélérer
apprendre c'est vraiment un processus
constant amusant alors pour apprendre ne
se sent jamais de partager merci
[Applaudissements]